we have a voicemail number and it is
pointing out that there are
right-wingers and Trump advertising all
over our YouTube channel take a listen
to this or the last few days whenever I
log into YouTube to watch David Pakman
latest post I get an invitation to a
survey from Action at Donald at Trump
comm it's wonderful that Donald and
company are using their advertising
dollars to support David Pakman
brilliant I watched the whole commercial
just to make sure that David's getting
the maximum advertising revenue yeah I
appreciate that
so that survey is the survey we
discussed in detail earlier in the show
it's a survey meant to frame the media
as the enemy of the people which is
something Donald Trump has been doing so
first and foremost of course Trump is
not spending money specifically to
target our audience most of the
targeting that happens on YouTube would
be happening sort of like target
political channels and so it's appearing
on some conservative channels and some
progressive channels
the other interesting advertiser is this
conservative I guess I don't even know
if it's broadcast or if it's just online
there's a conservative news station or
commentary or analysis politics opinion
whatever called CR TV and they are all
over our YouTube channel and my view
again is is the same one I've had before
which is given that we can't control
what advertisers appear on our channel
individually how great is it that a
bunch of the money they're spending is
being misdirected to an audience our
audience that is mostly not a good
target for them I think that this is
great and yes I think even though
YouTube isn't too transparent about this
the more of their ad you watch the more
we get paid and the more they spend on
that impression so let the ads play and
it's it's it's hurting us it's hurting
them and it's helping us and I don't
think that they're getting too many new
viewers by advertising on the david
pakman show YouTube channel on today's
bonus show we will talk about how
Democrats are now making gerrymandering
a camp
issue after the Supreme Court punted on
that issue is this a good idea is this
something people will actually vote on
in the state of Texas we'll talk about
that but we'll also talk about a new
study which says that doctors interrupt
patients on average 11 seconds into the
patient describing what they are in the
office for it's not been my experience
but I want to talk about that on the
bonus show and we will also talk about
yet another study which points to a
four-day workweek that is it's a very
positive study pointing out increased
productivity happens as a result of a
four-day work week and a number of other
positive indicators and we will talk
about how the david pakman show has sort
of taken a half step in that direction
we'll explain on the bonus show two ways
to get access to the bonus show david
pakman.com slash membership and
patreon.com slash david pakman show both
methods support the show and give you
instant access to the world-famous bonus
show and that is where I will next speak
to you